hi everyone sal here from khan academy  so for most of human history when we  were either hunter gatherers or early  farmers we had a lot of time where we  would just look at things and not be  over stimulated there'd just be a  bubbling brook  but now we're constantly stimulated by  social media by things we have to do at  school things that we have to do at work  our cell phones are in getting different  text messages and before we know it in  modern society our brains our thoughts  are taking control of us and we actually  don't have as much peace and as much  stillness as we would like and so one  thing that i found in my life is if  every day you take some time out to just  let your mind be still you start to  observe your thoughts that it can be  incredibly powerful it's going to  improve your mood and it's going to just  make you a overall happier and more  functional person  you